ET là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ET là
Le
[Musique]
se souvenir c'est vivre dont j'ai rêvé hier
toi
[Musique]
per clo dar me revivre hier dont j'ai rêvé
toi
[Musique]
gauche
bientôt
après
J'ai raté
rêve
mon grand amour
que vous
ET
[Musique]
peu après
il est revenu
Dieu me pardonne mais mène cette vie qui
Je suppose que c'est mieux parce que et se souvenant de la
semblant de la femme qui
abandonné mais augmente le désir que
ça me fait tellement souffrir
m'a pardonné
Bonjour, elle a encore raison
rappelé
dans ce temps heureux qui est resté
dos
J'ai beaucoup souffert, je ne peux plus y aller
mon Dieu
bien
pour pouvoir vivre hier j'ai rêvé de toi
a donné de
Tailler c'est vivre dans la terreur j'ai rêvé de toi
mais ils disent qu'ils peuvent m'appeler
parce que je ne porte pas cette douleur dans ma poitrine
jeter la première pierre oh oh oh
celui qui n'a pas souffert par amour allons-y
peut-être que tu peux m'appeler
c'est parce que ce n'était pas là, grâce à la douleur
dès la première pierre puis la
celui qui n'a pas souffert par amour
Je sais qu'ils vont censurer mon comportement
moi sans une femme qui va même me dire
Je suis revenu pour t'humilier
mais ce n'est pas grave, vous pouvez même
souriez alors il a été fait pour nous
demander pardon est fait pour nous
demande si tu ne veux pas de moi
allait
[Musique]
ne devrait pas me devoir
regarder ne doit pas me tromper
moi
laisse moi
tomber amoureux
si tu ne me veux pas tu le ferais
je ne devrais pas
cherche, je ne t'ai pas laissé me tromper
ne me laisse même pas tomber amoureux
[Musique]
dans la douleur
si
toi
avait l'air d'un
lier beaucoup
plus toi
inventé ma fille pour père femme moi
laisser dans
paix
sœur
je ne peux plus
oublie ton look
loin de mes yeux
Oh ma vie t'attend
te dire au revoir c'est
Le
appel
[Musique]
abandonner le
le mien et
plus d'aube
Cirino mes yeux le feront
courir
la tristesse n'a pas de fin
bonheur
Oui
tristesse
n'a pas de fin
bonheur
Oui
Christ non
ET là
tu as
vin là-bas
[Applaudissements]
Ouais ouais ouais ouais
[Musique]